hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach a new update with new SCPs have
been added to I believe but also I'm
playing the little box of Horrors mod
which adds four new scps a whopping four
and you can find this all linked in the
description below and also you can buy a
brand new I don't know what the hell but
either way I'm gonna play this so let's
get into it my name is murk and alright
we're back in the game now has been a
while since I've played and I'm kind of
hesitant to play with each small update
but with a whopping six new scps added i
am very eager to try this out okay I was
a little bit confused because I'm not
popping out where I thought I was gonna
be and also there's a dead body on the
ground but that doesn't bother her okay
so all hell breaking move up what the
fudge was that all right dad are you
gonna start this game on me yeah oh here
we go okay this kind of stuff semblance
of normalcy okay so I played it I
started it up just to test it out before
and uh hey I got to do hi buddy they
have this thing called a clipboard where
obviously you take all the pieces of
paper that you got from your SD Pete
travels and you can actually put them in
one place which is awfully nice - OH
hi excuse me can you fly now you wanna
yeah yeah oh you're not gonna do it
again okay I'll just I'll save
disengaged scp-173 can fly cuz if he can
I think we're all screwed okay
what's this really okay all right then
so that's the door that I've seen before
but I was able to open it before with my
card and I don't right hand now okay no
that's one of the new areas they've
added a whole bunch of stuff and this is
really dark why is it Bert I'm sorry
Owen bother you no more this is where I
bust through the window I think I don't
know is there another part in here yeah
there is
hello it's not in there haha what a
[ __ ] god dammit [ __ ] about the
cursing didn't expect that where did he
come from
you wasn't even in the room all I did
was blink my worst mistake I wallow a
scarred watching Doctor Who though I saw
the weeping angels and whatnot alway
look great
alway looks lovely all the way looks do
what is that what is that a skull safe
that's like what
no you where did you come from
no thank you
I know what Eddie Oh looks like my old
friend is finally did you open that damn
door you did you [ __ ]
are you able to open new corn I'm stuck
so bone oh there carton here I don't
know I've never been in here I've never
seen the skull I want to see the skull
but I can't see the skull kids I don't
have enough clearance just save thank
you all right I got a good buy him we go
where to go where to go where to go
where to
say that for some reason it won't let me
save every time I push the button that
door opens I'm in trouble a lot of
trouble well this has been quite an
eventful start did you give me what what
was that open before who's that who's
this the key what does it do when did I
get that I don't even know
oh whatever I don't know when I got this
I don't need this anymore so wasn't
there like a key something thingy they
were talking about early in like the
loading screens way long ago that it was
like some thing that um could unlock any
door so who's that who's that who's that
I see something there I see something
what is that what is that
ping pong ball I can't move
oh no no I refuse I've rinsed this is
the greatest work of wit this work of
art is the greatest I've seen my entire
life okay that's nice can you not could
you not I don't know when I saved left I
think it was David why do I see you I
feel I don't know sounds pretty probably
deadly can you not
who's there supposed to mean it means
you're gonna die so don't what they do
they get away from it please they close
the door on it
nope can I can I close the door on it no
I call my gas mask are you doing
my my still now I understand I
understand why
what do you understand let me go let me
go your dick I killed them
okay good good you kill them great good
job thing any not tonight this is my
punishment that's why I'm here
that is why I'm here alright you want to
explain - dumbass over here what's going
on their lives are over and it's all my
fault
crap I'm gonna die aren't I what is
their doing just a painting at death
just in the middle of an open room okay
I feel I feel weak and I'm back and I
can't move okay so I'm back here at the
key chamber that's good I guess
alright so now we come back to where we
need to go and not close that damn door
don't look at no no no no no close it
close it can this work yes okay
cool I got a key that I think can open
anything and I'm never did I push your
button wrong baby you want me to push it
better like with a key
come here alright alright so alright I
got the key from here that means this
whole area is a dead end and I need
never come back here
sack oh where was he
oh where am I now I don't know where he
gave up
oh my camera just moved my camera does
that for some stupid reason or something
in the game causes my camera just delay
yeah how I hit my arm really hard and it
hurts guys will you kiss it make it feel
better in one play but where is a I know
he's kind of forgot that he was there I
had other problems to deal with where is
he where where Oh there that would
explain why I died hey babe there we go
don't open that door
you [ __ ] I don't know what this s
people oh there we go
I don't know what this SCP does I'm
gonna find out what
well I died yabba carry-all doesn't you
die he'd cut stupid you're dumb
oh that was the thing Oh though it was a
keyhole not a key okay
oh oh stupid is it weird I'm you touched
it tough stupider you the hell there
isn't even like a document on it is
there oh there we go okay let me read up
hang on gimme don't don't touch
well if markiplier ever reads something
before doing something that'll be the
day when the world end so let's just put
that beside and pretend that never
happened okay
all right where are you you have you've
been kinda you you missed me I know I've
been away a bit with you can you back
there off and you go to hell and die I'd
beid life okay there's the music box
thingy that also kills you when you look
at it but at least that gives you a
chance to get away from it okay should
be fine
for now anyway
all right this has been fun
I'm never gonna play a game again which
way have an icon that this mental I'm
doing that did you see that just
flip-flopped my we closed doors behind
me cuz I don't want to surprise death
for my good friend
hello dick back my old friend who's that
that a tree really at reason SVP you
know the skull said safe to I don't
believe you okay well let me read first
no no I refuse to read anything before I
do let's do I said let's do I need a
kick let's go ah touch the tree water
man did why did it all break alright
I'll read it okay well here we go water
twice per day found a band farm apple
tree s growing things other than Apple
other than fruit clone any object that
touches its bark what whoa that's cool
that's weird oh okay so the people that
touch it age quickly and lets them to
work okay I want to talk to it I really
want to touch it okay all right I know
you all are very disappointed I wanted
to touch it too but life's full of
disappointments let's just be honest all
right where are you
what is this that's just a screaming
locked up door that's nothing that's
nothing new I've seen many of those in
my time this door however looks very
different what's the difference
oh I could stop doing that what I'm at
he's looking at something in the corner
of my eye
good thing I have this stupid key all
right that's even better than the Omni
card and easier to get all I had to do
with find it I think that won't all know
hi
here you got elaqid I lose thank you the
doors have changed okay was it I think I
hit my camera a while ago that's been
kind of off since oh boy
Omega silo this is where I if I want to
not blow up the world is where I would
go not blow up the world why have I done
this before
yeah no have I I don't remember if I've
ever actually finished the ending with
this time here before nine-tailed Fox
got here hey looky loo look at all that
it's a big old nuke
Let Me In Nikki card I got a key card
I got a Qatar it's so dark why is this
the dark okay so um I feel slightly
encumbered but at least oh okay I'll put
that on when I do the thing okay
off off okay so now they can't blow up
the place which is probably bad but it
means that I survived I'm such a selfish
bastard that I would risk all the SDPs
in the world escaping if it lets me
survive for like another few minutes
that's what I that's the kind of guy I
am in here in this game
anyway hey I think about last time
no no I yelled that but anyway so I'm
gonna keep going but this is it
pronounced go thank you all someone for
watching click damn people that I've
done as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh
oh no oh no I'm gonna run way better